and our shadow tonight for an incredible
series of investigative reports about
what might seem like a rather mundane
subject given all that's going on in the
world but these reports had real impact
and made lives better for tens of
thousands of people caught up in a
system that thrived on the belief you
can't fight city hall but that was a
call to arms for a reporter in Chicago
working for the nonprofit investigative
journalism group ProPublica and it's
Illinois Bureau the ProPublica
investigation discovered how and why
tens of thousands of Chicago motorists
had either lost their driver's licenses
or been driven into bankruptcy because
of parking tickets yes parking tickets
unpaid parking tickets but a story that
at first seemed hardly exciting 2
reporter Melissa Sanchez of the
ProPublica newsroom in Chicago
I wasn't even convinced my editors were
I'm convinced that it was going to be a
significant story and what made the
difference
I mean talking to people whose lives
were completely ruined by ticket debt
people like Rachel white of Chicago
whose plight was portrayed in the Pro
Publica stories of gas in my car to get
to work or do I pay this ticket do I pay
the light bill or do I pay this ticket
it sucks you know for every time you
make a little bitty mistake for it there
to be a dollar sign attached to it so
you got this $200 ticket which which is
which is a pretty big hit for a lot of
working families and when you don't pay
it on time it doubles that's 400 and
then after that the city sends it to
collections where there's more fees
added on it and it grows to four hundred
and eighty eight dollars and the missed
of me trying to get the money to afford
those tickets they would double so if I
couldn't afford it initially you know
how can I afford it if it doubles and
the investigation found police often
ticketing the same vehicle for the same
infraction several times a week so one
person could have could have easily
accumulated 1,500 two thousand dollars
in debt by just having a couple of
tickets on more car in like a single
week the city goes after people in a
really a grass
subways they you know they take care of
the impound your vehicle after you
accumulate as little as two or three
unpaid tickets and then they take away
your driver's license and under Rahm
Emmanuel's administration a few years
back the city really took that to a new
level and they suspended more driver's
licenses and they had in years prior and
Melissa Sanchez discovered tens of
thousands of Chicagoans actually had to
file for bankruptcy as a way to relieve
the debt and get their drivers licenses
back I talked to a woman who had a
hundred thousand dollars and ticket debt
and and they couldn't pay for it but
they really needed their licenses to
drive and they couldn't afford to get
him a city payment plants to be able to
start that process to reinstate their
licenses and the only legal option that
they could afford was filing for chapter
13 bankruptcy forced into bankruptcy /
parking tickets exactly and then working
with Chicago radio station WBEZ
Pro Publica tracked tens of thousands of
the tickets and discovered they were
being written mostly in primarily
african-american neighborhoods and that
let us say more definitively police are
issuing more tickets a disproportionate
share of tickets in the south and west
sides of Chicago where there's more
low-income black families living
whenever you wake up in the morning and
you know there's a possibility of
getting your car towed you feel like a
criminal you feel like a piece of
yourself is is gonna be gone
you know because yes it's just a car but
it's my car but it took a year and a
half long series of stories to get City
Hall and then Mayor Rahm Emanuel to
acknowledge the problem she says it
wasn't until a few weeks before he
ultimately left office that he publicly
acknowledged yes there might be a
problem and we will work to fix it but
now the reporting is having a major
impact Chicago's new mayor Lori
Lightfoot says she was outraged by the
findings this is way more than just
about ticket it this is about restoring
people's dignity this is about being
able to provide for your family this is
about giving people a real chance to get
to work and keep a job and just last
month
the Illinois governor signed legislation
that would restore the driver's licenses
of some 55,000 people tens of thousands
of motorists in the state can now have
their driving privileges reinstated
governor JB Pritzker just signed a law
eliminating suspensions for most non
moving violations it feels really good
and I hear it every day from the people
who called me I ever worked on something
have had this much impact nice to know
you can fight City Hall that's our
program for tonight we'll see you back
here next week